okay now
the second speaker today is virginia
williams
university and she'll speak on the
matrix
okay thank you
i hope you can hear me
okay
okay so
is this big enough
or should i write bigger yeah okay
so matrix multiplication as we remember
from basic linear algebra
is
the following operation
i threw away the other one because it
didn't work
so uh what we have i'm going to work
with uh an infinite field
in the stock
uh you can think of the complex numbers
for example and
we have the matrices live
and
let's say
so these are square matrices then we can
define
uh
their product is this so this is the
typical notion of matrix multiplication
and this talk will be about how fast can
we compute the product of two matrices
so when we talk about how fast we can
compute major uh
some problem then i need to tell you
what the model of computation is so
just like we saw yesterday
my model of computation will be
okay so the model of computation are
straight like programs or equivalently
arithmetic circuits so we saw the
definition of this yesterday where i'm
going to recall it again so a straight
line program is a sequence of
steps so we have an input
which is a bunch of variables x1 to xn
and the straight line program has steps
1 2 whatever
t
and then in step i
from 1 to n we're going to set um
we have some
value we'll get well let's call it gi
which will be
uh just we put we make it an input and
then for i greater than n
we're going to have uh
gi is some function of the previous ones
g
d j where
j is less than i and the functions that
i'll be looking at will be as follows
one one type will be
gj
equals
gi plus g
okay where i am k is less than j so we
take the sum of two
values already computed or
gi times gk
where they're less than this or we could
have
uh gj is uh
you know some
constant in the underlying field
or in general it could be a constant
times
a constant times
gr
our constant
plus gi
so
i have a bunch of these operations and
you can think of these
this type of straight line program we
can also think of it as a directive
graph directed to cyclic graph at the
bottom we have the input variables
um
and this will be you know g1 to check it
yeah
and then
we have
some gates
for example plus gate corresponds to
summing you can have
gates for multiplication
for example like this and and so on
um you can think of the scalar products
in addition you can have them on the
wires or you can have them and at the
gates it doesn't matter
and then
the this
uh the
graph goes from the bottom to the top
at the top we have some gate some output
gates and each output gate outputs a
polynomial because of the way we define
it
so yesterday we talked about time in
terms of
the number of gates in in the circuit
but today we're going to define a
slightly different
notion
of
how good
a computation is and we'll show how to
use this for matrix multiplication
algorithms
so
you could have
so cost
of a computation
okay the first one
uh let's say the time of computing a
polynomial f is the
minimum number of
gates
let's say
if let's assume that the
fanning is two
okay
and something else
is the
minimum
number of
product gates
so what this means is that i assign
to a computation of this form
cost one
and everything else has caused zero
all right
so this is also called the
multiplicative complexity and
this type of measure is called ostrofsky
measure
okay so
when i analyze matrix multiplication
algorithms i'm typically
concerned with
what actually the length of the straight
line program actually the time to
compute the whole thing uh but i will
also tell you how uh
getting a bound on this will allow us to
get a bundle in time
okay
all right so
good
matrix multiplication
is a bilinear function so you have
two matrices x and y and actually the
product is just bilinear in x and y
uh and so it's natural to consider
special k a special case of this type of
computation that's bilinear so what does
a bilinear algorithm for matrix
multiplication look like
so first we compute
products
of the form
of this
so i'm going to take a linear
combination of the entries of the matrix
a
for sum these things in the field
and multiply it
by
a linear combination of of the matrix p
okay so you can think of this as
uh
only only one layer of project gates and
then finally i'm going to
set
okay
so
i compute a bunch of products of this
form and then then i express the product
of the
the matrices in the ij coordinate is
just a linear combination of these
products
okay
so
if the number of products is
is r
so this goes from 1 to r
then if i could express matrix
multiplication in this way with our
products then
the multiplicative complexities in
particular at most
at most are
so the cost
uh
the cost becomes the most far
but then you may ask um
could it be much better and it turns out
what you can show
is that
for bilinear problems not really so for
bilinear problems
the
the bilinear complexity is at most twice
the real complexity so
i'm going to call
r
which i'll tell you why i care about
this
which is the min
number of
products
by linear algorithm
for n by n matrix multiplication
and
because
matrix multiplication is a bi-linear
problem
we have that
the multiplicative complexity is at most
this
true
general
or bilinear function
so when we're when we're talking about
yeah
oh
well that's a question of whether you
read this as lfc
yeah uh yeah okay
yeah so
uh anyway so why do i write start here
is because uh we could also allow um
divisions right but it turns out that
strassen show that for infinite fields
divisions don't help you
so we can just restrict ourselves to
the multiplicative complexity
okay and and moreover when we talk about
circuits we can restrict ourselves to
bilinear ones
because because of this constant
dependence here
all right
so why why am i talking about all this
so let me let me show you
why
well it turns out that
we have this lemma
okay
if
the rank
if for some constants
k
and
r
the rank
of matrix multiplication
like this is at most r then
for all l
greater than one integers
the rank of
m to the k
k
is at most r to the l
okay
so once we have a bound on the rank of
uh
small matrices we can uh make it make a
bound on the rank
for larger ones and
this time complexity
so now this is where i also count the
additions and multiplications
the time complexity
is at most order
all right
so if we if we write
n
to be k to the l then the time
complexity of
this becomes order
um and
log base
so
the reason why i care about the rank is
because i can convert
any
bi-linear algorithm
for small matrices into one for big ones
and this also implies a time bound not
only
not only the multiplicative complexes
but also for the full
complexion
of the problem
this is why we care about
only multiplications and how would you
prove something like this it's it's not
too hard so let's look at a
a k
to the l by k to the l matrix
multiplication
what we can do is just block it
into
a k by k
matrix
with
entries
are k to the l minus 1 by k to the l
minus 1 blocks
and then
we apply this algorithm here
where these aij and bijs here are now
blocks instead of entries in the field
and uh we then we compute this so so
basically
what we get
is
um
we do this p lambda
now this one is a k to the l minus one
by k to the l minus one
the same and then we do the sum
for c i j
um and now what's going on is when i
need to compute these
uh i just do a recursive
okay so what this means is um right
until i get just one by one
okay so this this immediately um so this
builds uh this big circuit and in the
end um
if if the number of products for
computing something of k to the l minus
one by k to the l minus 1 is r to the l
minus 1 by induction the number of
products for the full thing is r to the
l
so the argument is by induction but
what about the the complete complexity
when i also
take the additions into account
so what happens then well
i'm going to use a different color for
this
then basically i have to also take into
account actually doing the sums over
here how many sums can there be so
there's
there's r of these products
number our products then we have two of
these
to take care of of there's at most k
squared sums of a i j
and now the summing and you know the
entries over k to the l minus 1 by k to
the l minus 1 matrix
is this squared
and then finally i have to do these sums
which is also r times k to the l minus 1
squared so the number of sums is an
order r k
to the 2
but
r is a constant
for our purposes so in the end i get
that the time complexity over k to the l
is at most
time
at most r times the time complexity of k
to the l minus 1
plus order
r k to the 2l
okay and then when you solve this you
again get
that the time of k to the l
is order
um
is exactly what i want
so this is this is uh
so the reason why i only care about
products is because additions are cheap
for matrices they just take linear time
in their size so this is exactly why i
completely ignored them from now on
i don't care about products
okay
okay so now i can move on to the
more interesting
part
okay so now we're going to talk about
tensors
um
every bilinear function as we've seen
has a corresponding tensor force
that corresponds to it so if we have
some
bilinear function
from
some vector space
oops
cross v
and w and this lies in the field
to some u and so on
okay so then we have this tensor
corresponding to phi
that lives in
so i'm gonna use the coordinate notation
the coordinate notation
uh says that if i pick a bases for uv
and w then
then phi
of u
v
and the k coordinate is just
the sum of t i j k
of
u
so this is just a chord and a tensor
that we saw before
for matrix multiplication
what do we have so for matrix
multiplication the the tensor is just
let's say c
i j
equals
right we just have this but the tensor
is going to be um
i'm going to call this
and then
t i j k
is just going to be
rt
i1 i2
j1
j2
k1 k2 which is going to be
as we saw before only if i2 equals j1
j2 has to be equal to k1
and then
k2 has t equal to i1
all right so
this is some bizarre notation but this
is the tensor of an n by a matrix
multiplication if we do k m n
it's going to be
the tensor of
k by m
uh by
n layer
matrix multiplication and then dcc
okay
so
there's a direct correspondence between
uh bilinear
maps and
and uh tensors and i'm going to
actually introduce this tri-linear
notation
which is a little bit
more
it's easier to work with so here's a
tri-linear notation
um
okay the tri-linear notation is the
following
so
what does this mean
this means that
uh when i take the k coordinate of the
output i just look at its coefficient
the sum
and this is what i'm computing
and actually if you think about it i'm
taking the transpose here so for matrix
multiplication
the trilinear notation will just be
so in the ik entry uh this it's actually
the uh the sum over j of a i j and p jk
this is a
trailing notation of uh matrix
multiplication
okay
so now if i i look at what's going on
with these bilinear algorithms in terms
of trilinear
notation you will see something
interesting going on
so
okay
we have
so the coefficient in front of z k is
the sum over
lambda
of
linear combinations of x
and
so
in the trilinear notation what happens
is that
when we compute
basically we compute these products each
of these is one of our p lambdas from
before
uh over there
and then we take the sum of the p
lambdas here for each decay where each
one is multiplied by a coefficient
okay
so this is exactly what's going on but
if you write it out
um a little bit better you will see this
this exactly corresponds to um
t i j k is just the sum of the length
of
i
later one actually
can
decay
and this is actually
the sum of
our rank one tensors
okay
so
this
um i'm going to call this is a triad
it's a rank from tensor
where in the i
j k
coordinate is exactly all lambda i
alpha beta j
gamma k
and this is rank one
and then uh
by definition the rank of a tensor is
the minimum r
such that
t
is
a sum
of
our
so what's going on is now that
for bilinear algorithms we have an exact
correspondence between the rank and the
course of the corresponding tensor and
the multiplicative complexity of the
bilinear function
so this is why we care about the rank
of matrix multiplication when it comes
to algorithms
because we we have if we have a bound on
the rank of some constant size matrix we
can convert it to an algorithm for
arbitrary size matrices
in the arithmetic circuit model
so now what i'll do is i'll define two
uh tensor operations and uh
i'll i'll use them
so
okay
first thing i'm going to define
let's say for
tensor u
is in
and then another one q prime
i'm going to define
the tensor product
is just going to be
in coordinates is going to be
something that it's going to live in
okay
you see and then it's going to have
the following form
its coordinates are just tuples
and it's just going to be
this is the product
uh
a nice
property of matrix multiplication is
that
which i actually did
this earlier
is that
equals
okay so
all this means is a uh it has a nice
block structure i can just block it and
and the products of the blocks
correspond to another matrix problem so
that's all that means
and
a nice property of the rank
is
that
is always the product is it most the
product of x
okay then we have um
the following
other operation which is just taking the
direct sum
of these things
and
this thing is actually gonna learn
it's much easier to look at it
pictorially i'll define in a second but
basically what's going on is
um
look at this cube
and then the two tensors i'm gonna just
put them
here so this is
this is t1
okay and the other one
it's going to be
this one
so now basically what i do is i just
plop them
like this and uh
you can write out the representation but
basically if you write if you write the
this expression you have new variables
where the pairs are indices and and they
pairs them in the season they actually
use different variables
so the two
answers in the presentation of this
okay and another nice property of the
rank is that
okay
and all right
maybe can i make the comment yeah
so the tensor product and two bilinear
maps that you wrote down uh
from my lecture would be
a flattening of the tensor product for a
very particular one that you wrote down
so they use the same symbol but they're
actually different
different operations because one
previous would be in six factors
sorry
all right
uh this is actually pretty hard to see i
mean i'm just right till
okay so the final property of the rank
that i'm going to tell you about which
is actually particularly nice for matrix
multiplication is that it's basically
invariant under
permutation so what does that mean
so if i were
to look at
some permutation
let me call it high
on three elements then i can actually
permute um
you know the the order in which
things here are
written so
right
what's the right formula here and and
the right will be considered so
basically i will define some tensor pi t
uh and then i'll say that the rank of i
t
okay so
okay
by t let's define this
it's if i have some good uh
decomposition there's always some
decomposition
basically all i'm saying is if i have
some decomposition where uh these are
this is over uh the vector's place here
this
is over w then i can just swap u v and w
and this will
this will preserve the length
and i can similarly also
do permutations within the slices and
then it will still be
it will still be two and so so this what
does this mean
for example for the rank of matrix
multiplication
uh
so i can take any permutations of the
dimensions and it will still be true
so one of these doesn't quite follow
from what i've written but it follows
from the fact that
a
so basically uh
computing so the rank of a k by m by n
by n matrix multiplication is the same
as any permutation of the dimensions
here
and this is nice because it allows us to
uh symmetrize and this is this so for
example if i have a
like this
so as a consequence
so
all right so i mean before i get some
nice
bounce on rectangular matrix
multiplication i also get one for
squares and then
this allows us to start from
different constructors so what we when
we know from strassen what do we know
about small matrices so we know straws
and showed in a famous paper
and so this gave
bound on
matrix multiplication which is the time
of
mn
2.1
so
this exponent is called omega
so i'm going to define it finally now
this is what we study and
for a long time
the study of matrix multiplication and
evolved around finding better and better
bonds with the rank of small matrices or
maybe rectangular and so on
and this also first comes to
so this stress and show that omega is
almost
then
maybe i'm right
something like this and and this like
eight and and so this sort of
got us stuck
finding the bound the rank for small
matrices is actually a difficult problem
that we've seen before so a new idea was
needed
and this is where
uh
where we last in the last lecture we
mentioned
border rank so this is when borderline
comes in
so
they looked at 2.2 matrix multiplication
but they said i don't want to compute
this thing
and one can show that
i just want to compete
i don't care about this one and the rank
of the sensor
is known to be six
but it turns out that there exists
tensors so they show that this
which i will show in a second searched
it as
epsilon goes to zero they tend
to t which is this tensor here
and
a rank
five
so basically what's going on is that you
have these sensors that approximate uh
this thing and they
um
but they have smaller rank than we know
is a lot so let me
give you an explicit example so you see
this
and then i'll define border rack in a
different way
all right
so
i'm going to
compute the following products
epsilon is variable but
you can set it to a smaller number
all right so we have these and then it
turns out that if you look at what
epsilon p2 plus epsilon p1 is over here
you will get
exactly
plus something
so this suppresses
right so i get exactly this thing
uh
plus an error of epsilon squared so if i
were to divide this expression by
epsilon i will get exactly what i want
and as epsilon goes to zero this uh this
will go to exactly
the value that i want
and
you can write similar things for
this and this
and you will get
for example
2 minus p4 plus
all right again so the epsilon's here
are exactly the same and i get
that reception close to zero i get
exactly the same things so now i can
develop define the motion of the border
right
and i will show you why we still care
about bordering in terms of
uh
oh
and
okay
so for some integer h what i do is i i
get um lambdas
alpha betas and gammas just like with
rank except that no they're allowed to
be
polynomials over indeterminate epsilon
over the same field and then i
can decompose the tensor but now in this
funny way where when i take
when i take uh the sum of these uh
tensors here i actually get uh t's but
uh all up to an error of absolutely this
one
okay so this is this and now i can
define the border right here
is the minimum over h system
so this is kind of a funny notion but it
turns out that
there's this theorem
so
is is it clear that you can take a
minimum and not an enzyme
um
well
not immediately but okay
it's
if the borderline called
k
and m
omega the most
log
okay so how would you prove this so in
order to prove this i know i need some
prop purposes
is this equivalent to like your
implication
so what it's saying here is yeah that
well it's equivalent to this but in
terms of borderline
now i have border range all i'm saying
is that uh instead of just working at
rank i can take her an expression in
terms of border i can apply exactly the
same techniques that i had before but
now using something it can be
potentially smaller as we saw for for
this beneath hence right over here we
had the rank was six for the border
right was five so if i were to use
border i could set the rank i would get
a better boundary
this is all just the same
okay
so
here's some
properties
of
borderline
um
the first property is
again
for permutations and tensor is the same
the same as with the red
if i had
so this is nice so this means that if
the exponent
here of epsilon for t is h1 and the
exponent of
t prime is h
h2
then uh when i take the tensor product
the exponents only suffer
so this will be useful
and the third property is that
i'm not actually gonna use this but
okay so this will be enough to prove
this
and i'm just proving this
so you can see a very simple
way to to prove bounds in the maker
so how am i going to prove something
like this so the border rank um
at most r means that there exists some h
such that rh
k and n
okay so then i can symmetrize
so i take the tensor problem k and n
n k n and n k n
and what i get is
but now here
i get the sum of the edges so i only get
3h over here
so i i've applied two operations one is
to symmetrize so i flip the dimensions
and then i do a tensor product of three
pins
of kmn
and k and then
and when i multiply them like this i get
this tensor
and i only sum the exponents of the
epsilons then
uh
for
take
time so power
so what does that do i'm going to
over here
i'm going to write in
and then i'm going to
take
okay
and i'm going to use a fourth property
which is actually nice
the
the actual wrangler tensor is always at
most
okay
this is
actually also not too hard to see so
basically in the expression of
borderline you can just compare the
coefficients and you can see that all
you need to do is compute
only
only those terms
whose powers in epsilon are exactly
eight and there's no statements to
choose to appease
so
this is
this is an expression all i'm going to
care about is that this is a polynomial
h
okay so what happens now is i'm going to
convert this into a right
all right
so now i get the omega which is
okay
and then
if you look at what's going on here this
is
the length
of
3s
log r
over s log
n
plus something that goes to zero
so this is a constant and this is a
constant and this goes to zero
as opposed to
and so
uh so then i have my here
that
omega is at most
three log r formula
so this is typically how improvement
proves such thing and it gets more and
more complicated you use more and more
equations like you can use this
and so on
so here's one very important theorem
that we use over and over i'm actually
not going to prove but i'm going to have
a look at this this is a
thermal
and he said
if
the border rank
of the former
so if i have a bound on the border rank
of a direct sum of rectangular matrix
multiplication tenses
then i can obtain
the omega is
mostly tau
where
tau
is
a solution
of
so the important thing is once i have a
bond something more complicated than a
single multiplication matrix
multiplication tensor i can derive
a new bound on the makeup
and this this is a very powerful tool
that we use over and over
it allowed
shanghai to prove that omega is less
than 2.5
and then also allowed for the
development of more and more techniques
such as jasmine's laser method and then
so let's take a break here and
update something
good so uh again i'm going to give you a
little intuition on how to prove such a
thing i'm not going to prove the full
thing uh let me just define some another
thing about
something this is a
restriction
okay so
i'm going to say
that
a tensor t is a restriction of t prime
if
there exists
you know
linear functions let's say this is
okay functions where alpha takes
our e prime to you
beta takes v prime to v
and gamma takes w prime to w so these
are linear functions and then uh
t
is
actually uh
so this means is when i uh when i write
the com the composition
of t prime into triads then i i apply
alpha to the first one to the second
galaxy the third one and then i i get t
is the alpha
and the property
important property
is that uh
first
the rank
of tea
is pleasing
uh same holds for the bordering so if uh
if t is the restriction of t prime then
its rank is at most the rank of t prime
uh and another property
is that
um
the
oh yes
the other one is the following
the other property is that
uh
let's define the following tensor r
uh it lives
in
zero everywhere else
so it's sort of a diagonal
thing
then
um
at most r if and only if
t is actually a restriction
this is an important property so now
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
give you a relatively short proof of
a simple version of the sphere
using just this notion of restriction
i'm going to give this to this lemma
if
the border rank
okay so the border rank of f um
independent copies of nn so this just
means a direct sum of f copies of
f copies
uh if this is g then i actually can get
a bounded number like this so if you if
you look at there all i'm saying is that
k i m i and n i are all n and then
you'll get exactly the same inequalities
right there
so
all right
so to prove this
okay it suffices
to show
this uh
the border rank of
foreign
and the reason being is that then
then i'll get the border rank of n to
the s and to the s and to the s in
particular is at most
this
and then i can take limits and then i
get that omega is it knows the limit
well i just go to infinity of this
gff
okay
i'm sorry why the second line close
so i'm saying that if
um
applies this
because if i have a bound on the border
rank of f copies of this then in
particular i have uh an upper bound for
a single value
so i just drop this f okay
and so i said if i could prove this then
i will get what i want so then what i'll
get that this will go to zero because
i'll get s right here here and this will
be
um
log
the top
you're just erasing the
f
yeah
i'm just saying that if i have a bound
on the border rank of f copies of
something then that's really i have a
bound on one copy
so yeah this is just
so i'm going to prove something stronger
and then i'll get what i want
yeah
and to prove this
uh
i'm just gonna do okay
maybe at some moment
to mention this issue of additivity
so if we have additivity
then it will be much simpler so somehow
you have to do some gymnastics
because we don't know that or because
it's even wrong
yeah
maybe we have to understand why it's
kind of complicated it's complicated so
additivity is whether
um
actually the border rank of the sum of
uh of
copies is actually the sum of the
ranks but
uh if if it were if they were equal we
wouldn't have to do it because yeah if
it were edited it just would pull out
this factor of f and then you would be
back in your situation
it's not because it's important to say
yeah it's important to say are you right
if you were evident then i could just
say that this is equal to f and whatever
and then i could just immediately get
you
but i i can't do that because
it's not true
so
so let's uh let's do the gymnastics uh
yeah you're right
okay so
how do i prove that
i'm gonna put it by induction it's true
for
um
s equals one
by our assumption
or something like this so we're going to
prove it for induction assume it's true
for s minus one and we'll just do this
okay all right
so
first
let's look at
okay
this happens to be equal
just because
distribute that product okay
then i'm going to use this restriction
here
this thing
by our property that
the border rank
the likes of most are at the normal blog
so i'm actually going to
do it for rank over here and uh actually
just just as before i'm not going to
care about ages because they will
disappear like in the previous proof
when i took limits uh i can always if i
have something for bordering i can
convert it to right
with the polynomial block in terms of h
and then i in the end i'll be taking
limits in s so uh
the h will because it's a polynomial in
nature h of s will become log and then
it will
go to zero so it's a five selection to
show it for a right so i'm going to
the list of the restriction of this um
by a
property that the rank is at most part
is equivalent to
the tensor beer being a restriction
this becomes this
so this whole thing is a restriction of
g
s
which is
i'm now going to
do this thing i'm going to
say that
i can have
it's
if i have more copies in the rank is
only bigger
and then
i'm going to say well
yeah but then this
is exactly
the rank
of
this
tense
this thing
okay
which then
and then this biodirection
is at most
and so i get what i want
so what i do is i take my thing i
represent it as a tensor product i apply
this restriction thing right here and i
get that the whole thing is the
restriction of g copies of the smptes
and then i argue that the rank is
actually at most event of this nasty
thing which is a fancier product with
this diagonal tensor there but i think i
apply the induction hypothesis here and
i get another problem around and so
there's some
funny way to do this
but it's it's very nice to have this
notion where this person can play around
with it
symbolically and basically
um
the way shanghai approves his theorem he
says well uh tensors i use isolation
classes of fences under this restriction
motion
form a ring and then we can do
operations in this ring with the
bed and then
things become much simpler
so in the remaining 15 minutes i'm going
to mention something about
coppersmithing really good and i'm going
to
tell you i'm going to tell you two
things about one about lower bounds and
one about
a different approach for making
multiplication
okay so
two minutes on coppersmith planograph
and
later
here
diminishing returns but
what are we really doing so there's a
couple minutes
of this tensor which i'll just write it
in this tri-linear notation that i was
using earlier
it's basically
we have these variables x zero
to x
k plus one where q is an integer greater
than two and the y variables also looks
like this and you see it like this
and then
we have
plus
anyway this is an extremely symmetric
tensors and it has very nice properties
one of which is that
it's borderline is exactly q
plus two
the upper bound of q plus two is due to
clapper's method whenever the lower
bodies because this tensor is precise
so
uh
very a very nice thing on top of this
each one of these
here some of our eye of this some of our
lips some rather this
these three things okay over here and
these three things over here they're all
matrix multiplications
so
for example this one
is a
uh
one key one
this one
is a
q1
and this one has
one
whatever it's like
and all of these are one and one
all right so
it's a nice thing where it's the sum of
these matrix products and we would be
done if
you know if they happen to have
these joint variable sets because then
we could say that it's a direct sum but
the only problem is that this thing is
not a direct sum of a matrix problem so
um
the entire machinery developed by
coppers in the running grid and the rest
of
us is to
take this tensor
blow it up take a huge tensor power of
it and then study it a little bit form a
restriction of this spencer and say that
in this restriction we have we gather
direct some of the entrance products and
we analyze how large this collection is
and
uh what the dimensions of these make
experts are and we obtain a boundary of
a map
the entire machinery is
really sort of
it gets very messy and we use constraint
programs to actually
compute
a nice restriction and
in the big tensor power and
what enables us to get some
better bounds of omega than what was
known before is the following theorem
from copper smithsonian
so they define
some value
something they prove a tyrant
that analogous to
help to shanghai
shouldn't have
of the tensor
for this particular towel
is some bizarre thing where you take
a
limit
then you look at
uh
sigma so these are restrictions
of
t to the s so something like this
of the sum of
matrix coordinates
under sigma
equal to something
and
so it's a very complicated expression it
happens to be a
nice properties for example
team
and so the intuition actually is how how
close is this tensor to simulating a
matrix product this is essentially the
intuition and the theorem is that if
the value of
tau is the most
r and
something
okay
so if if t is f copies of the same
tensor and
the border rank of t is at most r
uh r is f
then
omega is at most of
three tau uh
where
now
f times the value of count
so now instead of having
so in the shanghai theorem we have these
sums with products of k i m i alive to
the top now we have this different
notion of value and we have a different
expression of what omega will be so then
it's a solution of this bizarre thing
so what we do in in the approach is we
take the accomplishment of great cancer
we blow it up into cancer power we
express each um
this tensor power get a restriction and
express the value of this restriction
in terms of the value of some tensor
that we will have to analyze
and
then it becomes very messy because we
have to write a constraint program to
analyze the value of the tensor and then
we have to solve this equation for this
and this this this thing
can be very nasty it's a non-decreasing
function of tau
but
it's a constrained program that it's
difficult to solve so the entire
approach becomes various
so there's things that i can't read well
so the definition of this value the
exponent is one over sigma here what is
one over x
is
so the point is now i uh i have to find
some decomposition of t into these t
primes that i
into this t prime whose value i can
analyze
because of some
reason and then i have to solve this
to find out
yeah because basically because of my
voice is
where sigma are restrictions of t to the
s the s tensor power of the tensor of t
that
restricted t2ds into a direct sum of
matrix products
but then how is the argument
yeah so each each restriction gets
different dimensions for these matrix
problems right and so this
is it a number like it's it's a measure
of how much matrix multiplication this t
can support under
when you degenerate
yes
so if you recall this this thing was
what was this thing was what was in the
shanghai theater
oh i can't read is it somehow
yeah so in the brackets this is the
product of the directions k i m i and
light
to the tau power
right
and what is the sigma
sigma is you take the
s tensor power of t
sigma is a feminine sigma ranges over
all restrictions of this tensor power
into a direct sum of matrix products
i'm not
okay
all right so this is what's going on so
i i take your restriction uh these are
the dimensions of the matrix products
that i get under this restriction then i
i take this thing which is exactly what
we had in the shanghai theorem
okay and then i take one over s
because
okay and then
then i take the limit and this is what
the value is
it's kind of a complicated thing but it
uh
it allows you to prove uh prove this
theorem here
it's complicated to write down that's
conceptually very simple conceptually
all we're saying is i want to simulate
a matrix product whose uh
so that shenharve's theorem will give me
exactly this exponent three tau and i'm
saying that i just take this restriction
and get this and i apply it kind of like
this
so conception is very simple
um
apply it
as you can see this becomes
more and more complicated and a little
bit
we want to have a more formal discussion
of what we're looking at
and actually what's going on here is
that
there's actually some
paper that shows that if you restrict
yourself to this particular answer
uh you only
consider arguments in this form that use
the notion of value like this but then
yeah you cannot get better than 2.3
for q equals five and no more than 2 or
2.25 so let me write this down
so
there's a new theorem that says
essentially that you can't achieve or
maybe equals to if you restrict yourself
to this
this argument
so
the theorem
of
just recently showed that
uh
if
called personal wounded white
so this is not very formal but i'll tell
you what it means
and
the tcw or tcw is distance
this particular printer
and then
the
best
brown
on
my
is
2.25
which for me is nice but
this also means that if we restrict
ourselves to any of the arguments that
we have been using with this tensor we
won't be able to reach a negative plus
two
okay
so i want to mention
uh
finally
sorry
is there a reason why you use bit
exactly with tender
is it nice in some sense or it's nice
because we know exactly what its border
rank is we know that it's a sum of
matrix products we it has also some
other non-structure like which is
exploited that
if you map the indices here between one
and q one
and the ones to zero then you get one
one zero and
basically there's a particular block
structure that you can exploit
to get the arguments to work out
and you can show that there's a lot of
tensors that have this property but we
just don't know
others through which we know such a nice
bound from the border
just make a comment more conceptually
the all these things are sort of
exploiting the gap between rank and
border rank and and
this tensor
has a huge gap between rank and border
rank and it's probably
one of the largest gaps that
had been known certainly at the time
that was known
so
that's that's sort of the secret
that's not in the paper
i don't know any formal proof of this do
you know
that if you have a huge gap then
something all right
i
we could discuss
it's definitely a lot of kitchens too
cute close something
anyway so
this is
this is the state of the art of the
upper bounds there is a nice approach
that doesn't use this framework based on
group theory which i will just give you
uh the notion and i'm not going to give
you a proof of everything and i'm going
to give you one example of how one would
prove actually through the lower bounds
of the rank
so
i wonder what this means if you use a cw
like argument okay
is it
zeroing out so all it's saying so the
way it works are these covers and
renegade arguments you take the tensor
power and you uh you take blocks of the
x y and z variables and you zero some of
them out and you obtain some
restrictions so they say if you restrict
yourself to this type of argument where
you zero out stuff and you obtain the
attention of the
sum of matrix products then
then you won't be able to get better
but suppose i didn't do zero accounts i
did some degeneration or something else
into
matrix parts and this they already know
as far as zeroing out meaning is a kind
of restriction it's a kind of
restriction so a restricted restriction
it's a restricted restriction
yeah i take x i if i set x to zero then
i'm zeroing out
i j k probably okay put t hybrid careful
okay that's the type of restriction just
kill off one of the
eyes
and
yeah so if i only use that to get a
directional matrix products and use this
particular text i won't
exactly exactly you cannot get better
than that yes
that's what i understood paper paper
thank you
okay so
now
three minutes on something called the
group theoretic approach which is very
interesting to me
okay
so there's there's two papers one is by
conor newman's and another one the
column was
okay so then uh what do they do so
instead of instead of doing all this
stuff with the
borderline and so on we're going to take
g to be some group
and we're going to look at its
algebra over the complex numbers and
we know that this is isomorphic
oops
probably yes
okay
and
these
the eyes
okay
and what's nice about this what we're
going to do is we're going to define
um a property of a group such that we
can embed matrix multiplication into
products over the state
and the nice thing about products over
this thing is that we can actually
compute
products
and
roughly
you know ideal matrix multiplication
over each of them
that's just the sum
so if we could embed matrix
multiplication
into a product so we'll take a matrix
simple embedded into here the other
matrix into here perform the product
over this and then can extract the
product of the two eight matrices from
the product in here then we would be
done we would actually get a bound on
the matrix multiplication
so in order to do this they define
something
property
triple
product
property and they say
well g
realizes
a and
if
there exists subsets s
and g and i'll have to do something
they're just substantial s
is k
t
is m
and u this is n
uh such that
uh whenever
s times s inverse
that's prime lambda
t times t prime inverse times u
plus u prime inverse for s s prime s
t
prime over t
u u prime u
all right so the triple from product
project property says uh that
there exists substance of the group such
that whenever this holds for any six
elements then they have to be s must be
as private you must be declining
so then
then what you can see
so then what
we'll do is that if we have such a group
then
then we can embed matrix multiplication
it's just a coordinate expression
for what you wrote down earlier that's
the
tensor corresponding to multiplication
in c g
you can zero out some entries and obtain
the m and k matrix multiplication yes
yes that's true let's do it
and just also write it like this i can
also embed
um
okay and then i can read
this
all right and then if i look at
is
exactly
so
why is this
okay because the s u inverse coefficient
has s c
plus s t inverse
times t times u inverse equals s here
okay and this this is exactly if you
look at it it's exactly the equals one
so this means that
t inverse equals t
so the reason why i want this triple
product priority is to
actually be able to embed matrix
multiplication and then
what happens is that you can show
that whenever g satisfies this
this property then you immediately get a
bundle omega and
and that will be
basically you get what you want i want
you to write something
i don't know where
so then their theorems will just focus
in here
if
g
realizes
and then
so
that's all and then then what they do is
they actually in the second paper they
find a group
that realizes
matrix words so that this
expression for that group actually gets
something non-trivial and the the
algorithm they obtain is actually
completely different from anything we've
seen before in terms of our our other
tools
so it's a very
open question of whether this group
theoretic approach
can give us something completely
different are they actually equivalent
approaches or yeah so the nice thing
about
what they
they can do they can actually reproduce
or maybe a lesson 2.376 of their pen
um
i'm not sure about the later
developments but problems
it's a similar problem so now you're
looking for a group with a particular
property as opposed to before we're
looking for small tensors for which we
understand the border right
but somehow you need to solve the
puzzles and you find what's called
straight we run into property of uh
finding the initially solvable puzzles
which was also defined
but really some
so the
i haven't defined any soluble puzzles
but uniquely solvable puzzles are uh in
a sense very related to
a paper-based person
and
it's a restricted version of from what i
understand from what we've been doing
with the copper's network
anyway this is not i don't want to talk
about this i just wanted to mention
there is a different approach out there
that we need to understand does anyone
tried the medical stability of this
uh
has anyone tried to implement the
situation
actually i don't know if anyone has
actually tried uh for
yeah i don't think that there is a paper
by old featuring demo but did they do
the group theoretical culture i thought
i don't think that he lies because
it don't rely on the approach what was
the question
numerical
this kind of algorithm doesn't kick in
until it matrices the size of number of
atoms in the universe
so because i understand i understand but
uh maybe the other approach actually
gives something that for a certain size
of matrices is better than
notion of stability you have to define
it it turns out that all these things
are stable i mean even the group
doesn't matter because they are all
the the framework is always that you
have an algorithm for a specific
dimension format and then you the tensor
ring
this is
all behind this this is my understanding
and i think
from that essentially there is a paper
about communication cost is that what
you mean no no i'm referring to this
paper by uh
jim damon
you can read it there and you can see
what kind of definition of stability
they use yeah i know they have one for
for um
um
but um if you consider
here's the group
they say age is
symmetric group
then h squared is this
squared and
this thing
is
where the action this is the semi-direct
product the action is to swap the two
factors
they want a group that's as close to a
billion as possible yet still robust
enough to
admit this degeneration so it turns out
that this a billion groups won't give
you
yeah
so for this one they get a
2.9
or something
i don't know
it's like 299 or something
no i thought it was 2.99
it's less than three okay
and it's different
so okay
uh right
lots of questions
okay but i think the time is up ok ok
so why